give first so in last week's book video
I was talking about the importance of
making connections to help grow your
business the fastest way to grow company
is to make alliances with people who
already have your target audience and
find a way to work together today I want
to talk about how to go about making
those introductions and forming
alliances it starts with giving it
starts with not asking for something but
giving them something first to help
build a relationship you're speaking to
their self-interest is a way that you
can help them without asking for
anything in return and some people you
may never ask anything in return and
some people they may not reciprocate
when you do ask but it's the easiest way
in where you have an opportunity to help
them you're not just going looking for
advice or just looking for help or
saying hey can you please introduce me
to all your customers well I don't even
know who you are so why would I do that
give first and so how I applying this to
my book Ryan Holliday is somebody who I
I flew to New York recently to meet we
just did a video on him top 10 series
you can check it out it really helped me
by the way if you can comment on it or
share it on Twitter or you know promote
it in any way it really helped me a lot
thank you guys and Ryan's in middle
promoting his new book and I said hey
why don't we have you on the channel
let's do a video together will help
promote the book will do an interview
give you some exposure and of course is
going to say yes when I went down to
meet him he was asking what I was up to
and one of the things I was hey I'm
working on a book too and his natural
reaction was to want to help me and said
hey well let me see it I love the help I
love to give you some ideas why don't we
go for breakfast and talk about it some
more hey I'm also connected to Tony
Robbins and James Altucher and these
other authors and maybe there's a way
that I can connect you to them for your
channel and to help you with the
marketing when your book comes out and
it's all great and it may seem like this
just fell on my lap but had happened
because I gave first I was willing to
fight in New York to meet him to put a
video up on my channel to showcase his
book and what he's all about and give
him some exposure and so that's a start
if there's some way that you want to
build a relationship with find a way to
give first i did a video with Michael
Gerber I did video with brian tracy i'm
working on projects in the works with
Louis house and
ravine or Chuck and a couple other
people and I'm always giving first let's
have you on my channel let's talk about
what you're up to is talk about your
books in your programs and what you're
trying to do and let's get some value to
my entrepreneurs who are watching my
audience and let them learn a little bit
about you and then when it comes time
for my book to come out it's easy for me
to tap these guys again and say hey I'm
in book launch mode are you guys able to
help me out and again not everybody's
gonna say yes and that's totally okay
but it's way easier going to somebody
that I've already helped and they've
seen value than me going cold and say
hey I've got a new book can you guys
help me promote it it's a big difference
so when you're approaching these
partners look for ways to give first and
a lot of times the follow-up just
happens naturally because they will want
to reciprocate and find ways to help you
too let's get to the questions first one
comes from Matt how did you start Evan
how do you decide to do what you do
what's your solution when you've got
decision fatigue there are three or four
things to do but you can't seem to focus
on one thing I know there's a book
called one thing but it's easier said
than done love your channel like an
inspirational guru without ego and
sports cars on her totally normal keep
spreading your good stuff alright well
thanks to that last part I'm glad I look
normal it's great how do I decide what I
what to do I I decided what I wanted to
do with entrepreneurship I'd sold my
first company I was started to be asked
to speak at a bunch of events and I
guess I haven't told the story in a
while so it's a good chance the YMCA
local YMCA asked me to come and speak to
their audience they had an entrepreneur
program and said hey can I share some of
my success as a 22 year old entrepreneur
who just sold his business and I said
happy to and I spent all this time sent
like weeks preparing for I promoted the
people that I knew they pointed their
program and I put a lot of effort into
it making it look I want to change the
lives of the people who show up and
getting ready for the first day I
remember like I'm showing up and in my
palms are sweating and my heart beats
going really fast and I get to the
elevator and like have to calm myself
down like doing this public speaking
thing and I showed up when we booked
this huge room lots of people you know
anticipated to come and I walked into
the room when there were three people
who were there and my heart sank and I
felt like a failure I felt like you know
I spent all this time marketing
promoting this thing and they had a set
audience and nobody showed up to the
first thing like three people right big
failure how was ever going to make money
from this how would the
ever be a career how would I ever build
something off of this if only a few
people will show up to a free thing and
I just said to myself after that initial
disappointment you know what three
people showed up I'm gonna do my thing I
prepared let's go and try to help these
three people and I left feeling amazing
I love feeling like I had an impact on
the on the people who did show up and
that that time spent was important to
them and I didn't know if I would ever
make a business out of it I didn't know
if I would ever be able to make money
out of it but I knew that I had to keep
going because of the way that made me
feel and that's why I encourage
entrepreneurs to explore explore explore
explore explore until you find the thing
that makes you come alive that made me
come alive I knew I had to keep finding
ways to do it whether it was speaking I
didn't know where ago was speaking books
I didn't have a youtube channel you know
none of this stuff existed it was my
first gig here in Canada and I just knew
I had to keep going and I think in terms
of finding what to focus on the two bits
of advice for you or give us one I would
try to combine them I would try to not
just do one or the other but try to find
a way to do both of them in a way that's
never been done before in a way that's
unique to you that somebody else can't
just copy and rip off because you are
generally passionate about these
multiple things or two if you're just
okay about a lot of different ideas then
quit those and go explore until you find
the thing that you love I didn't know
that speaking was going to be my thing I
didn't know the helping entrepreneurs is
going to be my thing up until then I
hadn't done a lot of helping
entrepreneurs but just the feeling that
it gave me made me feel like I had to
had to find a way to keep going I would
do this as my volunteer time because I
loved it so much and so between those
two ideas hopefully something there that
helps you next up is VIN do you send
your whole work sasha novel to the
publisher so when you work with a
publisher there's a couple of phases
that you go through the first phase for
me was they need to know what the book
is all about but it's just a pitch deck
so it's about the topic of the book and
more important for them as your audience
they almost don't care about what the
book is about until they know who you
are so they want to know who I was what
my track record was who my audience was
more and more the publishing houses want
to see the authors can promote and sell
the books themselves and I'll have to
rely on the publisher doing a lot of
work that's the first step just
quick overview of what the book is going
to be about attached to it then they
want to see a sample chapter so then
they want to see okay well what's
chapter 1 or chapter 3 or chapter 5 look
like in your book they want to see that
it's meaningful as impactful that you
can write they're not just putting other
ideas and money behind some person who
looks good on camera but can't actually
you know put words on paper and then
from there is when you sign an agreement
and from there you get an advance
ideally and it's not always possible but
I got in advance and you know it's
usually spaced out and then you start
writing the whole book now at the point
where the book is has gone in there were
in the final copy edits we're going to
get a permissions and approval and all
this kind of back and forth I just got
it back yesterday so I need to go
through it and look at it and then
that's basically the final stage and
then we could start marketing very
exciting Ricardo hey Evan will do the
book be available in audio yes I
ventured a couple times yes it's going
to be an audio I'm insisting on reading
it I don't know how the process is going
to work out but we've been approved for
audio and deluxe ebook which will
include 30 minutes of video attached to
the book as well so I got to figure out
what i'm going to do with that video
time but definitely going to have an
e-book available and as soon as i know
the details about all that stuff i will
let you guys know Danielle very
inspiring there's no difference if
you're helping three people one day or
three million the next just do it the
numbers will take care of themselves my
husband and I can now see why you are 50
year old sons idol keep up the great
work we can't wait to read your book wow
that's that's that's pretty powerful and
meaningful to me thank you for sharing
that I kind of wish that when I was I'm
really jealous of this generation like I
wish that if I was 15 and I had people
on YouTube that I could look up to and
learn all this stuff I wish I could
learn it a lot younger than what I'm
learning it now I'm still going through
the process but I really that's
massively humbling and super appreciate
you letting me know kind of made my day
so thank you Kevin start my day with
this Thank You Evan one question just
started my business and I feel audience
sharing is a bit weird why would the
other person want to help me I know I
can add value to their audience but how
do you present your idea to them in the
first place so that's back to the topic
at the start give first look for ways
that you can give to them
help them out and improve their business
somehow if you have some kind of
audience can they come on your show or
your channel or your newsletter list
write an article for your website
something to give them value first form
the relationship and then again almost
always they'll look for ways to
reciprocate immediately but if you have
a specific ask for them like if they
have a podcast or they have YouTube
interviews something that's not super
outside than the norm for them then it's
pretty easy for them to usually say yes
but give first I'd value to them first
before you worry about what they can do
for you Paul looking forward for the
book e-book plus videos and all the
other exciting authors thanks I
appreciate it Paul feeling the love and
again as soon as it's ready I'll let you
guys know so you can check it out you
know Joe great advice and tips I was
wondering when first starting out on
YouTube what kind of tips do you have as
far as getting on people's radar and
finding those creators similar to your
style that I really like to collaborate
with so for somebody first getting on
YouTube one I would make sure that I was
being consistent that really helped me
it still helps me now but helping when I
was getting started and that I kept
putting out content I kept working on it
even though nobody was really watching
it it was more for me to get better
people talk about quality or quantity
which is more important at the end of
the day you need to have quality videos
because just pumping out quantity of
crap won't help you get anywhere but the
quantity helps get you to the quality me
doing it over and over and over and over
and over and over again how many times
made me better so you need to put in the
work to continue to put out content even
if nobody is watching it because it's
your growth your development your
message gets refined and slowly you
start building like the hard core
audience that they stick with you I've
had some people who've been with me for
years and a lot of you guys are a lot
newer and then you build yourself up I
think in terms of finding collaborations
the ones that I found most easiest were
people who are already looked at their
channel I was already a fan of their
channel I like what they were doing and
I could speak to them so it's not just
from a business point of view like oh
they have my audience I'm gonna go see
if I can work with them you want to make
sure that you know about their audience
right you are a fan you are leaving
comments you are subscribed and you're
sharing their stuff and the people who
share my stuff the most people leave
comments every day I know who they are I
recognize them and so they were to ask
you for something to be a lot easier for
me
say yes so its first start with the
people who you already are subscribed to
you already are fans of and see if
there's a way that you might be able to
do something together because you you
already share some similar kind of
values because you like watching their
stuff arrest 2103 hey Evan you should
contact the guy named aaron anastasi
he's the founder of a super successful
online singing program and it's written
a book on personal growth does really
awesome plus is a super nice guy group
video as always I haven't keep with the
good work I appreciate that connection
never heard of him but I haven't heard
of a lot of people so if you can
facilitate that or if anybody else can
let me know i'm i'm curious to know more
super successful people who are also
nice guys that's like that's that's good
good check marks in my book so if
there's a way you think we can work
together you can introduce me somehow
I'd really appreciate that Simeon I
regularly watch your videos keeping
track with the new ones I'm extremely
enjoying every one of them I love your
work really give me inspiration that
every other young person needs to jump
in cold water and do what he loves I
love it man and feeling the energy as a
first-year student studying computer
science I was thinking of starting the
crew as an entrepreneur because I'm
totally sure this is thing I want to do
in my life my question is the following
as I have a couple of ideas and we'll
start working on them something appeared
in my mind how can we know if an idea is
worth trying or spending time on I know
you say that we need to take risks but
we can't be sure of anything and working
hard and wisely I'm quite passionate
about starting working on my ideas but I
want to first figure out whether they be
helpful to society or would benefit
someone and grab people's attention
moreover I want to know how we can
distinguish a good idea from a bad idea
continue with the great work this is a
really interesting question in my view
when you are starting to business you
want to connect two things one is the
thing that you love doing you're really
passionate about with what adds value to
people's lives and it's not just listen
to the customer and give them what they
want because you may not like that if
you are doing work just for the customer
and you don't enjoy the process of doing
that work you're not going to have a
really successful business it's got to
be something that you love doing as well
and combining those two things together
that's where you're going to find a real
business opportunity you can make money
in any industry there's a lack of
creativity in every industry there's
opportunities in every industry so the
idea itself is not about is it a good
idea or bad idea it's much more about
the execution
do you love this thing people would if I
go back to my story about walking to the
ymca people would look at that and say
that's a bad idea it was a total failure
of a first event that three people show
up to a free thing after tons of
promotion that's a failure right how are
you never going to be a successful
speaker you're not going to be
successful helping entrepreneurs look
what happened the first time you tried
to do it so on paper it sucks but when
you're starting a business you need to
have the heart the heart is much more
important than the head you don't want
to be making those important any
important decisions in your life with
your head it has to come from the heart
and so I loved doing it and so I would
find a way to create my own opportunity
around it and so all these ideas that
you have you don't want to just be
thinking well does a customer want this
it's definitely a good conversation to
have I would be looking at the ideas and
think what are you most excited about
creating because being a programmer
you're going to slave away spend days
and days and weeks and months creating
code and if you are only looking for a
customer pay out you're not going to put
in the work like you've got to love the
coding process and feel like what you're
making is important it's important for
the world is important to you and so
I'll be examining my list of ideas and
seeing which one makes you come alive
the most and that's where I'd probably
spend most of my time doesn't hurt to
talk to customers and get them involved
and see what they need to see in it to
make it be successful you're not just
creating in a vacuum in a bubble but if
you only listen to them then you're not
getting up with a product that you
genuinely love and gets you excited and
that's that's dangerous if you're trying
to build that successful company last
comment comes in from Paul dude enjoying
watching your growth thanks Paul really
appreciate that and and for me I love
watching you guys in your growth I love
seeing in the comments of things that
you're working on and how the videos
that we've made helps you grow and the
new things that you've tackled that's
that's the impact is what drives me
motivates me so if something has helped
change your life leave in the comments
below because that's what peels me every
day they want to go and keep making
videos for you guys so thank you so much
for watching I'd love to know what you
think of the topic about giving first
you have questions about that or if you
want to share
you're doing it leaving the comments
below if you have a question about my
book or the book writing process you can
leave the question below to and I'll
answer it in next week's video thank you
guys so much for watching I really
appreciate it continue to believe and
i'll see you soon